let's see if we can evaluate the
indefinite integral
1 over
9 plus x squared
dx
and we know that if you have the pattern
a squared minus x squared it could be a
good idea to make the substitution x is
equal to a sine theta but we don't see
that pattern over here what instead what
we see is a squared plus x squared and
in this context it tends to be a good
idea it's not always going to work but
it never hurts to try out there's a
little bit of an art here to try out x
is equal to a tangent theta now you
might say sal why is that well let's
make that substitution and see how this
thing would simplify this thing would
become a squared plus a squared tangent
squared theta which is a squared times 1
plus tangent squared
theta and this right over here this
right over here we could reprove it
actually let me just reprove it for you
this is going to become a squared times
this is 1 could be written as cosine
squared theta over cosine squared theta
tangent squared is sine squared theta
over cosine squared theta
and this is why i picked cosine squared
as the denominator so that i can add the
two and this is going to become a
squared times cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta all of that over
cosine squared theta this numerator from
the unit circle definition of trig
functions becomes one so this is one
over cosine squared theta and everything
simplifies to a squared
secant squared theta which might
simplify things so let's see if we have
what's going on over here we could
rewrite this so 9 plus x squared
9 plus x squared you could rewrite as 3
squared plus x squared in this case in
this case a would be equal to three so
we'd want to make the substitution x is
equal to three
three
tangent of theta and if we wanted to
solve for x you can divide both sides by
three because we're later gonna have to
undo the substitution x over three is
equal to tangent
theta or theta is equal to arc tangent
or inverse tangent of x over three now
we're also going to have to figure out
what dx is we're also going to figure
out what that is so let's take the
derivative
or
we'll write it in differential form dx
is equal to 3 derivative of tangent
theta with respect to theta is secant
squared theta
d theta so now it looks like we're armed
with all of the things necessary to
rewrite this entire integral it's going
to be equal to the indefinite integral
you're going to have dx here which is
equal to
secant squared theta
d theta that's the dx
and it's all of that's going to be over
reducing this
all of that's going to be over
this business right over here our a
squared plus our x squared
now we already know what that's going to
simplify to our a squared plus our x
squared is going to since we made this
substitution x is equal to 3 tangent
theta x is equal to 3 tangent theta is
going to simplify to a squared secant
squared theta so this is going to
simplify to 9
secant
squared theta and you could re you could
essentially
go through this logic you're going to
get 9 plus 9 tangent squared theta
factor out a 9 you get 9 plus
9 times 1 plus tan squared theta and so
that's going to be 9 times secant
squared theta exactly what we have here
lucky for us we have the secant squareds
cancelling out the secant is cancelling
out you have 3 over 9 this whole thing
can be rewritten as 1 3 that's just the
3 over 9 times the indefinite integral
of just
d theta which is equal to
1 3
theta plus c and now we just have to put
things in terms of x and we see theta is
equal to arc tangent of x over three so
this is going to be equal to one third
arc tangent
of x over 3
plus c
and
we are done so now we know how to deal
cases where we might want to where we
see something like an a squared minus an
x squared and an a squared plus an x
squared it won't always work but it
might be a useful it'll it'll definitely
allow you to do this thing it might not
always make the integra and it might not
always make the integral solvable but
it's not a bad thing to try when you tr
when it looks like u substitution isn't
working then you could look for these
patterns and try some trig substitution